I asked a psychologist how to change
your emotional state in one simple step
and here is what he said we think that
our thoughts and emotions create our
Behavior which they almost certainly do
so if you feel happy you smile
but there's a kind of back Channel which
is that if you force yourself to carry
out the associated Behavior influences
your thoughts and emotions I.E you force
your face into a smile and you feel
happier and that's that is a William
James notion I think he refers to it as
if principal I'm not quite certain now
in other words you behave as if and then
that creates the thoughts and emotions
foreign
[Music]